why do popular franchises fail
i think that it gets back to
when
the filmmaking turns inorganic
and i think that that's hard to describe
when that happens and what that is but
it's it rings true or it doesn't and
when a popular film goes in a direction
that doesn't feel authentic to the
characters and who they are and their
motivations as we've seen over the years
then that's where the franchise can be
derailed and
that is why top gun maverick's a great
film is because it's
very true
to everyone
from the 86 version to now the 2022
version uh to the to the sequel is that
it is organic and it's grounded in who
these characters were so that's how you
do it right and then we've seen how it's
done wrong where you just watch and you
go wait that character would never do
that or what was that decision and it it
almost always just comes back to
something that feels inauthentic
inorganic
and often ungrounded and and that's uh
i think tr you know what happens a lot
of times a lot of filmmakers try to do
too much i think there's value in not
doing a lot
um you know i look at the darden
brothers and talk about
their style of filmmaking is just so raw
and so rough no score just just here it
is almost documentary style that is
there's value in that i think that if
every filmmaker found some value in that
bringing everything down it's rarely
about bringing things up it's usually
about bringing down the level a little
bit right
uh even in hustle that i watched last
night there's a scene where adam sandler
has to talk to somebody who's trying to
save his career and you're watching adam
sandler and i'm going uh he's doing his
comedic thing where he's out of control
almost he's yelling and i'm like if he
would have grounded that just bring that
down here then it's better and i think
that's obviously up to the director to
do that because they they're in charge
of the actors but as a screenwriter
your job is to again just keep the
motivations of your characters as
authentic as possible and i think
ultimately for me it's always about
bringing things just a little bit down
it's rarely about ramping up it's
bringing things just down sometimes a
lot but let's just say even that much
just that much is significant right
so if it's very often i see that it's
usually less it's always less is more
almost always 99.9 of the time less is
more in everything in film
which franchise is in the worst shape
right now i think marvel's in trouble i
mean listen
doctor strange too multiverse of madness
is not
a great film okay and again
when i watch that film i see
times that i see sam raimi and then
there's other times i don't it's almost
like there's two films right and it
feels like it was cobbled together and
nothing in that film ever rises to a
level you can watch so many films and
you have some that really pop something
in the movies just like oh my god
and and then we've had plenty of films
that you really are pinging that top
right dr strange never even pings it's
just a flat line and and you go back to
eternals
and and what chloe was not allowed to do
with that film clearly i think marvel
really needs
thor love and thunder to be
essentially a home run i think that
people are the brand is starting to feel
to feel devalued and i think that also
speaks back to the disney plus shows
there's too much product remember less
is more
it's it always just comes back to that
essential core
less is more and now we've got more is
more and you've got all these shows miss
marvel and she-hulk and and uh
what's in a moon night uh all these
shows i don't watch the the marvel shows
i just stayed with the cinematic
universe but when you start asking your
audience to watch shows as homework in
addition to everything else you're
starting to make your audience right
you're starting to bring your audience
down and i don't know what the i
understand they want to have a bunch of
successful shows but the more you do the
more work you require like dr strange if
you didn't watch one division you're
like what right you it was required
viewing to watch one division and i
don't think that's the best path so
they're marvel's in this state where
they're trying to figure out how do we
work
our
disney plus shows into our cinematic
universe organically and i think it's a
challenge for them because not
everybody's watching the disney plus
shows and therefore the impact of your
film is going to be lessened because the
people don't have the experience that
they need to really value the film at
the level that it needs to be to be
truly appreciated because you don't have
they haven't watched it it's like
watching a sequel to a film you never
watch the original you're not going to
have the same reaction at top gun
maverick
as you did
if you'd seen top gun versus you've
never seen it you're just not
it's the two in combination that is
where that comes right that's where you
have that experience that is next level
because they work in symphony with one
another and and that is i think marvel's
problem right now is that they have
their disney shows and they're trying to
combine them with their cinematic
universe and it's not really going that
well it's i'm sorry
strange too is not a good film eternals
it's very mid and then you're sitting
here on thor love and thunder and let's
just hope tycha went batshit with it
because if he did then maybe we could
get back on track the fact that
guardians are back in this film is
obviously a win for them this is pretty
much we're getting back to that core
avengers group right thor and the
guardians you're back to the avengers
more so and i would also argue going
back to strange that doctor strange is a
supporting character he's not a lead
right not cumberbatch car matches is a
badass okay
a great actor but
as a lead i feel like doctor strange
supporting very much as we saw him in no
way home he's not the focal point and i
feel like thor is more of a focal point
focal point
so thor love and thunder should be
better off that way hemsworth and thor
more of a focal point as a main
character for me than dr strange but
there's a lot of pressure on thor love
and thunder
so having a film where the audience
needs to catch up on prior
episodes or or universes or whatever is
is a recipe for disaster
you're asking listen anytime you ask
anybody to do more work
they're largely gonna probably not i'm
good i don't want to
back to downton abbey uh i haven't seen
abby one or abby two and the reason
cause i never watched the shows someone
said well you don't need to abby two is
a really nice gets you up to speed right
off the bat when you go into it i'm like
i don't care i don't watch the shows so
you're asked you're limit you're
restricting your audience and again
you have if that's what you want to do
that's that's your decision but again if
i'm making a film i still want to try to
make a film that is as accessible as
possible to the widest group of people
not every film is going to be that but
for a marvel film it better be right
that is
accessible to everybody at better be
so
when you ask them to watch for homework
wandavision or
moon knight whatever that is you're
asking them to to sit through eight
episodes plus go to the movie i i don't
know i think that's the challenge for
marvel right now is again how do you do
that so you are limiting your audience
when you ask them to do homework outside
of the film
are there any franchises right now that
can do no wrong
um
uh i i feel like jurassic worlds run its
course so i i don't know we're gonna
find out here with dominion um
you know that's a good question what
franchise i mean we obviously have
marvel we have dceu
um
i i can't think of any franchises that
uh i'd have to have a list in front of
me because i can't off top of my head i
can't even think of a franchise and
think like could this be in trouble
mission impossible if you look at
mission impossible seven um obviously
great trailer you've got tom cruise
who's coming off of maverick it's going
to be a huge hit next summer but at the
same time have we run the course with
mission impossible
it feels more so the answer to that is
yes uh but you know tom cruise puts his
heart and soul into every film and he
can't help but like the guy so i imagine
it'll be still a winning enough film
but for me i still want to see something
original i mean ultimately i'd rather
see a really good original film that is
self-contained and doesn't require extra
homework i can just watch this film get
caught up in this universe this world
that the director created the writer
director came up with this film and i
get lost there and i don't have to do
all the homework i can just watch this
film
so i think that's where my head is i'd
rather watch one
singular vision of a film that is start
finish one thing one project and not
have to have like a franchise i'm more
into those things
why does spiderman do so well
spiderman no way home did did the
numbers it did almost 2 billion
worldwide because it delivered
everything that you want out of the film
and some people call it fan service fine
uh there's fans out there and they need
to be serviced i mean
it's not a bad thing uh again if it
feels organic and it doesn't feel forced
if the fan service feels like oh we just
threw all the stuff in here because we
want to do it but it has to have a
purpose and i think no way home is a
very good film at delivering
what the audience wanted to see from
that film i mean everybody wanted to see
all three spider-man right and not only
did you get them you got them
in a large amount you expected them to
be a cameo right you expected both of
them to come back and andrew and toby to
be in the film for uh maybe five minutes
but no they're on the whole back half of
that film and that was a great very
smart move by sony uh and marvel is is
allowing them to be back because people
didn't just want a cameo they really
wanted them back and they now created a
universe where they could actually make
films with both of them again if they
really wanted to you've got the spider
verse you could do almost anything with
it now um and top gun maverick same
thing same same thing as no way home it
gives the audience exactly what they
want and there's nothing wrong with that
again if it feels grounded organic and
doesn't feel forced and just thrown in
there to be thrown in there it feels
like it's actually part and really
legitimately deserves to be there
like top gun maverick and like no way
home those are both 100 crowd-pleasing
home runs and there's nothing wrong with
giving the audiences exactly what they
want
why is dr strange the best movie of 2022
so far
that's definitely not true
that is 100 false uh doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness is definitely
not the best film of 2022 and for the
reasons we've discussed i mean listen dr
strange feels like multiple directors in
here it feels like almost like a test
screen movie right where multiple
audiences sold and said i like this this
let's put these things together it
doesn't feel cohesive there's no moments
in doctor strange that ping the top not
one uh doctor strange is definitely not
the best film of the year the best film
of 2022 thus far is a tie it is x tai
west horror film and it is top gun
maverick and for the for the different
they're very different films but very
clearly it's about direction for both
for me it's tai west there and it's
kozinski on maverick anytime you have a
strong directorial footprint on a film
i'm going to like it and that's probably
why i don't like doctor strange as much
as some no one by the way has said
doctor strange is the best film of the
year there's nobody if you if you have
said that reevaluate all of your
cinematic decisions from here back
because there's no way that that's the
best film of the year no chance
okay so if direction is so important to
you yeah
then let's talk about just quickly the
safety brothers yeah oh god so you have
one film that you absolutely love
by the safety brothers oh yeah which i i
would praise as well but you have
another one that i love
probably just as much which you say
needs to be fixed in some areas okay so
good time
is i mean listen if we're gonna
pick two safety brother films obviously
they're they're most the ones they are
the most well renowned for one good time
and two uncut gems uh good time is is
here uncoachement is here and here's for
a number of reasons
one
the one of the big ones for good time is
i don't remember the last time i saw a
film
that was it's about 90 minutes but at
the end of good time it's over and you
literally the credits start rolling
you're like my god the movie's over i
don't think i've ever had that feeling
where you expect the film to keep going
and it literally no no we're done he's
in the back of the squad car the movie's
finished
it's tight
it's dirty it's raw it feels like raw
new york conversely when i go to uncut
gems i look at that film there's so many
things wrong with uncut gems
i mean for starters the length the
length is bloated it's two hours right
bring that to the 130 135 better film
and here's how you do that first of all
i know you want to do the mining stuff i
get it i understand you want to do the
gem mining that goes on the colonoscopy
does not work okay i would completely
eliminate that is gone from the film you
can start with the mining but you don't
need to do the colonoscopy okay that's
out and i think even if you don't even
want to do the mining you can even get
rid of that the film opens on adam
sandler on his phone which is where the
film really brings in right that's the
start and i think if you make that
change that film is better also the fact
that the safety brothers are huge nba
fans i get it kevin garnett actually is
very good in the film but
it feels like and with the weekend as
well that it's like hey we have these
people that are big and successful like
the weekend and or kevin garnett we gave
him a big part but the weekend like this
just because he wants to be in the film
let's put him in
it doesn't fit organically in the story
it feels forced it's like hey we need to
put the weekend in the movie right it's
like let's put the cameo in there but
it's not really needs to be there and i
think the safeties got lost from from
uncut from
good time to uncut gems the safties got
too much of like hey let's put more in
our film when remember it all comes back
to less is more and that's why
for me good time it's not even a contest
if you go back and clean up the things i
said about uncut gems i think it's
actually all there the film
uncut gems is there it needs to be
literally carved down and then you're
going to get a film that's better that's
those are the worst films too when you
see a film that has the elements all
there and you have extra pieces strapped
on that don't service the movie as well
as they should and or frankly aren't
needed that brings your film down it's
like wow i can't believe you actually
brought your film lower you lowered your
film
by doing more
less is more almost always